[Applaudissements]
alors dans le signe des temps parce
qu'ils accordent aux talents voir l'un
des meilleurs européens et je me suis
dit alors j'avais demandé un panier bon
j'ai pris le plus grande de la banda
s'est déjà reste très bien qu'il est il
est donc en paniers de basket
non ne l'avait pas la tête droit droit
droit fait un truc normal pour une fois
droit c'est un excellent basterds way
essayé de me mettre au moins trois
paniers voire trois paniers là bas rhin
pas les plans attention et non je
suivais mois dernier
mais j'ai toujours aimé d'allumer
gilbert noël voilà abord il faut l'aider
comme ça carrément aller encore 1,27
soit d'accord
ah ouais voilà merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]